jessica ate two slices of cake and nadia
ate four slices if jessica ate one
fourth of the cake what fraction of the
cake was eaten
what fraction of the cake was eaten so
we're gonna have to figure out the
fraction of the cake is eaten is number
eaten
number of eaten over total number of
slices total slices
so we actually do know the number eaten
jessica 8 2 nadia 8 4. so together they
ate six slices so the number eaten is
going to be two plus four is six
six slices eaten and now we have to
figure out the total slices well they
tell us that jessica ate two slices of
the cake and those two slices are
one-fourth of the cake so let me think
of it this way the fraction jessica ate
so the two slices two slices
over the total slices so over the total
slices
over the total slices is going to be
equal to 1 4. so whatever the 2 divided
by whatever the total number was is
equal to 1 4. and so there's a bunch of
ways you can do this one way is we can
cross multiply four times two slices is
going to be equal to eight slices eight
slices i'm multiplying the four times
the two cross multiplying is going to be
equal to the total times one is going to
be equal to the total so we have eight
slices in total and that makes sense two
over eight two over eight is the same
thing as one fourth two slices is
exactly one fourth of eight slices so
our total slices are eight so the
fraction of the cake that was eaten 6 8
but we can simplify this even more both
the numerator and the denominator is
divisible by 2 so let's divide them both
by 2 and get into lowest terms
6 divided by 2 is three
eight divided by two is four so four
sorry three fourths of the cake was
eaten